Thank You Jamie oh this is embarrassing
okay so you know I'm very interested in
understanding how digital media use
affects people and I'm particularly
interested in how multitasking impacts
people when they're using the devices
but I want to first start by explaining
what I mean by multitasking so the mind
governs the allocation of attention and
generally attention is gold directed but
when the mind allocates attention to
different sources and keep switching
back and forth then that's multitasking
so Don Norman and Mia
have found that this can be triggered by
something external to us like an email
notification when you're on your
computer or something internal like a
memory that leads you to pick up your
phone or check social media so Monica
Smith writes about that from an
evolutionary perspective multitasking
was advantageous because people had to
continually scan the environment looking
out for predators looking for food and
those people who could multitask wealth
had a survival advantage so multitasking
is not new we've always multitask but
what is new from an historical
perspective is that information workers
are almost always within reach of lots
of different sources of information that
they can access within seconds or even
milliseconds so I want to go over some
really import results with respect to
multitasking and performance so first of
all as far back as 1927 it was found
there when people multicast
it slowed down their performance
and if you're working on one task but
you're actually thinking about something
else something you just did or something
that you're about to turn to this can
increase cognitive load and if you're
working on a task and then you check
social media and then you go back to
your task that Facebook post can stay
with you and create interference on your
current task at hand and in our work we
found that the total daily switches of
computer screens was correlated with the
lower end of day self-assess
productivity measure and multitasking
and stress has some important results so
first of all lab studies have
consistently shown that multitasking
causes stress measures of biomarkers and
perceived workload higher blood pressure
and also in situ studies have shown this
so in our work we had people wearing
heartrate monitors in the workplace and
we found that when they multitask it was
correlated with higher stress and it's
also been found to correlate with
perceived stress in the workplace so how
can we study this well we can bring
people into a laboratory but if you
really want to understand real-world
influences and what people actually do
in their real-world environments we have
to go where people are and so we create
living laboratories and so to this end
we use a variety of different measures
so we measure stress through heart rate
monitors and wearables we measure mood
and focus through experience sampling
and these are probes that people get
continually throughout the day and this
measures the participants subjective
experience of what they're doing we
measure face to face interaction with
with sense cams and these were developed
at Microsoft Research we log computer
activity we measure
physical activity and sleep through
wearables and then we take a whole lot
of different demographic and personality
measures so there's no single reason why
people multitask
with digital media so there are
individual reasons so some people
actually prefer to multitask it's called
poly chronicity it's a small proportion
of the population some people are more
susceptible to the information that's
available on devices you can think of
this as natural curiosity some people
are more susceptible to interference in
the environment like that email
notification coming through and there
are differences in cognitive control and
executive function there are
environmental reasons so in the
information workplace people are
consistently juggling competing demands
the reprioritizing tasks research has
shown that the scope of work has
expanded so people are actually working
on more different projects that they
switch to in the workday and this last
point is really interesting because it's
not just computer screens that people
are seeing switches on but it's actually
exposure to the wider media landscape
people watch film and television and the
average shot length for television is
three and a half seconds there are
social reasons so there's peer pressure
for people to check email for example
and social platforms like email and like
slack involve an exchange of social
capital and what this means is that I'm
going to answer your email because
someday I'm hoping you're gonna answer
mine so there's this exchange of social
capital and so we're all in this
interconnected web and so if any
individual decides that they want to
pull out that person would be
lust so it's very hard to be able to
pull out there's technological reasons
so there are increasingly more
sophisticated ways to target information
to grab our attention and of course
there's just a sheer availability of
information on our devices
and there's also affordances of the
technology so we can have multiple
screens open multiple tabs on our
browsers and all of these serve as cues
that just invite us to click on them and
switch our attention so how much do
information workers actually multitask
so to measure this we can look at
people's average duration of focus on
any computer screen this is a good proxy
for how attention is being shifted and
we find that with all computer activity
the average attention to raishin is 47
seconds this is day in and day out and
actually the median is less that's 40
seconds so attention duration has been
tracked over the years so back in 2004
Victor Gonzalez and I found that the
average of ten generations on a computer
screen was about a hundred fifty seconds
and in 2012 Steve Boyd and I found that
it was about a minute and 15 seconds and
since then you could see that these
average attention durations are
relatively simple Attili similar so
people switch a lot in fact the average
checking email seventy seven times a day
for those people in our sample who check
facebook they checked it on average 38
times a day there are individual
differences in focus tration
so we did a factor analysis and we found
a factor that we label lack of control
so people who lack control have shorter
attention durations on the computer and
they are characterized by people who
score higher in neuroticism this is a
personality trait higher in impulsivity
urgency also a personality trait these
are people that are more susceptible to
stress so at this point you're probably
thinking well maybe switching isn't so
bad if it's the same project we're all
academics when we work on a paper we're
looking at a word document and then we
need to switch to the Internet we switch
to email so maybe it's not so bad
so we clustered activities at the
project level to see how long people
paid attention to any individual project
and this is the general pattern that we
find so people work on project a then
they switch to project B then they
switch to project C and then they start
to work on project D and then they
resume work again on project a so people
average about 10 minutes and 21 seconds
working on a project before switching
and it the average about 25 and a half
minutes in order to resume work on that
interrupted project and what's happening
is that people are working on an average
of over two projects when they interrupt
a project and so this means that there
are cognitive shifts from project to
project these are pretty strong
cognitive shifts so let's talk about
interruptions so I do not want to
express that all interruptions are bad
there are costs so interruptions can
lead us to be distracted from work
they involve contexts
ting which increases cognitive load
leads to higher stress but they also
have benefits so they can afford a
mental break from work which allows us
to replenish our mental resources and
also the allow us to connect with others
either online or face-to-face and
interestingly we found that about half
of all interruptions are self
interruptions and what does this mean
it means that if you're an observer and
you're watching someone for no apparent
reason that person will suddenly stop
what they're doing and they will turn
and say check email or make a phone call
so there's no identifiable external
stimulus that's leading them to make
this switch so what predicts
self-introductions so there are several
things so first of all the
organizational environment so people in
different organizations self interrupt
at different rates people who work in an
open office environment self interrupt
more people self interrupt more in the
morning
compared to later in the day and this
last point is interesting we we took the
self and external interruptions and
divided them up into hourly segments and
we found that the higher external
interruptions in the previous hour
actually predict more self interruptions
in the subsequent hour so it's as though
people are just determined to be
interrupted so people would study
attention for a long time and they've
used different terms to study ating
attention you're probably familiar with
the notion of flow which is a very deep
immersive state of focus and these
studies have consistently showed that
when people have attention focused it's
associated with positive effect positive
emotion
and when people are bored its
consistently be shown to be associated
with negative affect so we can look at
this dimension we call it engagement and
this can represent attention focus from
being highly engaged in doing something
and not all not at all engaged and we
envision that there was another very
important dimension to consider if we're
looking at attention concerning
information work and this is challenged
how challenged as a person in what
they're doing and we came up with this
theoretical framework to understand
people's attention 'el states when
they're working with digital media so if
a person is highly engaged and highly
challenged we label this as being in a
focused state if a person is highly
engaged and not at all challenged we
call this a rote activity and the best
way to think of this is imagine playing
solitaire you're really engaged in
solitaire but you're not at all
challenged with it and if people are not
challenged and not engaged we label this
board and if people are highly
challenged and not engaged we call this
a frustrated state and the an example of
that is you know you have a bug to try
to solve and it's really challenging and
you're just not really into it so
contrary to all these studies that
showed that attention focus is
associated with positive effect if we
introduce this dimension of challenge we
find that people are actually happiest
doing rote activity which could
potentially explain why people do social
media in the workplace or why they play
candy crush because it makes them happy
so let's look at how attention is
distributed throughout the day so if we
look at the white line that white line
represents focus and this comes from
multiple experience sampling probes that
people answered throughout the day and
we find and people don't come to work
you know in a focus state you know ready
to work but it takes some time T dead
into a state of focus and they peak
about 11 a.m. and then they peak again
about 3 p.m. and you'll notice here that
people's peak focus times actually
coincide with when people are checking
their inbox and calendar so every time
we study people we interview them and
the number one thing that people claim
interferes with their ability to focus
is email and so we've studied this and
we we found two important things the
first is the more time people spent on
email the lower is their self assess
productivity at the end of the day this
is a pretty robust result but if you
really want to understand causality you
have to do an experiment and so we found
an organization that was willing to have
some employers cut off email for a work
week and we studied that and we found
that when people were cut off from email
for a work week their focus was
significantly longer on any computer
screen without email and the flip side
of that so another way to look at
attention duration is to look at the
switches per hour and we see that people
switched about half as often when they
didn't have email and we measured stress
people who are heart rate
monitors around the office and we as a
measure called heart rate variability
and we found that people were
significantly less stressed without
email and I want to note that the higher
the measure of heart rate variability
the lower is stress so now I want to
talk about some future trends in
information work and how this can relate
to multitasking and people's attention
management so the first trend is as AI
and personal digital assistants enter
the workplace they're going to be
handling more information that's routine
so AI is not good at handling ambiguity
or a complex decision-making but humans
are and so people are going to be
switching but the context that they're
switching back and forth from are going
to involve more complex information and
this is going to be challenging so with
the rights of the gig economy and
globalization teams are becoming more
diverse and fluid with changing
membership and with new people coming
into the workplace they're bringing new
workplace protocols and new practices
with media and this is going to affect
multitasking there is continual
development of new ways for people to
communicate online and with more
technology channels this will afford
more different ways for people to
communicate with other people more
switching and some argue more continual
communication we are already seeing the
borders between work life and personal
life being very porous and so there are
already social expectations for people
to be monitoring information sometimes
24/7 to be
on call and so this is moving toward
what some call a state of permanent work
so to sum up these these future trends
it's predicted that people will handle
information that will be more complex
involving different kinds of practices
in teams with changing membership for
more different information sources over
expanding hours so what can we do well
what humans can do so brains are
malleable and there is some research
that shows that some exercises can help
people focus more exercises like
mindfulness training and there's some
promising work with video games that can
help people focus longer we can change
our behavior it is really hard though to
break habits especially if they're
really strongly conditioned requires a
lot of discipline we can schedule time
for deep work each day and studies have
shown that taking a 20 minute walk in
nature can replenish resources and make
people significantly more relaxed and
Sayyid Abdullah was a research intern at
Microsoft Research he did a study where
he showed a 20-minute walk in nature led
people to score significantly higher on
divergent reasoning tasks we can change
our interactions so in our work we found
that if people are really engaged in
their work they can use social media as
a way to take a quick break and get
right back to work and so if people can
utilize online interactions in a
strategic way this can help them
replenish resources and stay on track
but this is hard to do and not everyone
can do it so what can organizations do
so New York City has already been
talking about legislation for the right
to disconnect and what this means is
that people who do not answer email
after hours should not be penalized
there are already German companies that
have policy that employees would not be
penalized if they're not answering email
after hours work can be designed to take
advantage when people's peak focus hours
are and last Sweden is doing something
that's pretty radical there they're
thinking about shortening work hours and
this is actually the reverse of
Parkinson's law so instead of work
expanding they're talking about that
work would still be accomplished if
there were shorter work hours in the
week so what technology can do so we can
draw inspiration from film directors who
are experts at designing when to create
tension and when to create relief and so
computers and smartphone technologies
can do the same thing by sensing user
stress and suggesting when it's time to
replenish resource when it's time to
take a break Eve come on was an intern
at Microsoft Research and she helped
design a conversational agent that was
designed exactly to do this and it
showed promising results that to help
people prioritize their tasks and be
able to focus more so throughout history
psychologists have talked about this
notion of homeostasis and this means
internal balance that people have this
drive to achieve an internal balance
Hippocrates talked about it as a
harmonious balance the gestalt theorist
talked about the law of Pregnant's
Walter cannon is one who coined the term
thisis my favorite theory of all is Kurt
Lewin's field theory which is this
Universal theory that says people have
this drive to reduce tension in their
lives
haider talked about it as balance theory
and you're probably familiar with
cognitive dissonance theory by fest into
it and that's when people are out of
balance when there's a disconnect
between their attitudes and their
behavior so in sum there is a need for
multi-faceted solutions to enable people
to achieve better balance when they're
working with digital media this was work
was done in collaboration with a number
of really great colleagues who I'd like
to thank and thank you
[Applause]